hey what's up guys my name is the
Chennai welcome back to my dimension
series last time we talked about
something really exciting how to build a
2d renderer check out that video if you
haven't already will be linked up there
we've just begun this amazing journey
it's gonna be so much fun
but what I thought that we would do is
kind of take a look at the quarry button
now and it's true about all the good
parts from it specifically the stuff in
sandbox obviously what I'm talking about
not just the general engine because most
a bit of course is good code but
specifically the stuff that's in sandbox
we want to strip that out maybe put some
of it into classes and we kind of want
to eventually have a clean slate from
which we can start preparing like a 2d
sandbox and then that's gonna kind of be
where we test everything and could even
be the place where we actually make a
2-d game from the stuff that we actually
build up in this series so today we're
going to be talking about camera
controllers nothing at the moment what
we've got to do with specifically like
with cameras is we just have a bunch of
stuff in our on update function and I
think that's about it and that's just
the stuff that controls a camera and
we've got this all the graphic camera
class which contains a projection matrix
that we make an orthographic projection
matrix and then we we just have some
loose kind of code around that to
actually set the position and rotation
that's fine but I don't want to be
manipulating the camera in the kind of
in this kind of example layer class
that's obviously very temporary what I
want to do is actually create an
orthographic camera controller in the
engine code base that you can use to
actually control an orthographic camera
and this isn't necessarily something
that you would use in a game because
most likely it's not going to behave
exactly like you want a camera to behave
like if you're making like a 2d
platformer or a top-down game you
probably want the camera to behave in a
certain way and it's very likely that
you know a camera is something that is
so much kind of client code so much like
game side code because it's the behavior
of it is so intrinsic to the actual game
that you're building that in real games
you know you would build a camera as
like as a Lua script or as some kind of
script there's a part of like your
actual like it like an entity in your
sin that would be the camera you
wouldn't just kind of use a camera that
the engine comes with however when
you're first starting out and you want a
basic
kind of like what unity would have in
their level ever for 2d or for 3d you
know you need that an engine should be
able to provide that for you so that you
don't have to be like okay cool
I've started a new project in hazel I'm
gonna have to just do a bunch of camera
scripting before I can even see anything
on the screen like that's not that's not
something that we want so we need to
kind of bring that code out we're gonna
add stuff like it's like zooming in and
out and a bunch of other stuff probably
to the actual camera class
well we'll create a new kind of camera
controller class and we'll talk about
that just so that we don't have to deal
with all this code inside sandbox before
we begin just want to thank all the
patrons who made this series possible
patriarchal force at the Turner is the
best way to support this series and
everything that I do here on YouTube
you'll get a lot of really cool stuff in
the Hazelden branch I actually pushed
like three three commits like I think
today each of that developing branch
that was to do with Trudy stuff I'm
going to actually merge a bunch of the
Trudy stuff that I've done ahead of time
into that hazel development branch
because of course in the future 2d and
3d are gonna have to play nice so you
guys want to jump ahead in both 2d and
3d and see what hazel is capable of and
what we're building towards then helps
both series and you will get access to
that card okay I'm not gonna do too much
talking we're actually gonna like jump
in and do some code here because there's
not too much to talk about we're
basically going to make a class called
orthographic camera controller that's
going to be it's basically going to be a
wrapper around a camera an orthographic
camera which is a class what we already
have and it's gonna add some extra stuff
to actually control that it's gonna have
like an update function where we can
actually process key events and it's
also gonna have an event and that'll be
able to handle stuff like window
resizing as well as you know Mouse
scrolling and stuff like that so that we
can zoom in now so let's jump in and
take a look at the code
okay so scrolling through this code we
have a bunch of stuff inside our on
update function this is sandbox app dot
CPP you can see this is all inside
example layout this is um and also this
file also has our sandbox
application this was kind of the first
thing we started off with in hazel and
it's great and it's a nice little
sandbox because you want to have
sandbox just to run random coding but we
also want to actually have a whoops look
we also want to have like an actual 2d
sandbox that we can play around in so
that as we're developing our 2d renderer
or we can have like a scene setup or
something like that and we can actually
have an example of how to make a 2-d
game without you know all of this kind
of boilerplate code that we don't
particularly need so that's what we're
gonna do today we're gonna start
cleaning stuff and in the future in the
next few episodes I'll probably will
have like a I probably will have like a
dedicated maintenance episode to just
clean up a bunch of stuff because
obviously we kind of accumulate more and
more tech debt there longer we write
code and I'm kind of putting off fixing
all of that episode 2 episode just
because I want to get these concepts
across and kind of be more effective I
guess in my teaching style rather than
actually cleaning up irrelevant code
like as I come across it which is well
it was something I would do in the real
world if I was actually programming and
I'm kind of going through this code and
I see something that I don't like I
might fix it just immediately then and
there that's kind of a good way to go
but with this of course I don't want to
randomly be distracting myself being
like oh I actually you know what we
should fix this so I will have a
dedicated maintenance maintenance
episode and maybe maybe not the next
steps over the tips but the episode
after there just a fair warning I'm sure
expecting something exciting then
there's gonna be a missions episode soon
all right cameras so let's take a look
at this orthographic camera class so
it's really simple as you can see it's
really just a bunch of matrices and then
some very very basic code around that
everything has to be set inside this
actual class I mean it's got its own it
does keep track of its own position and
rotation it's not literally just a
projection and a view matrix and then
that way you know you have to set
everything manually from the kind of
outside of this class nor it does have
that stuff and that's right but we want
to actually take it a step further and
add input to this class now I don't want
to do this right this is just data
it's pure data is pure maths we don't
want this to have anything to do with
input we want to tie it like that at all
because what this is and what does this
represent and in fact I'd probably be
inclined to even get rid
position and all that stuff from this
class because what this should be is a
representation of an orthographic camera
which is really just a representation of
a projection matrix and a view matrix
these two right all together a view
projection matrix this is what it is
and this is why it exists we want to
send this data to the renderer that is
all that this is anything extra is stuff
that we add to make controlling this
data a little bit easier but ultimately
we need this to exist because we need to
be able to get this data to our shader
so that we can multiply that these
matrices with our vertex positions and
with our actual object transforms EEPROM
if need be to actually position vertices
on our screen inside our display area
inside our rendering area correctly
that's what this is for so we don't want
to start adding extra stuff to this
because the more we add to this class
the the bigger it will be the more data
it will contain the more bandwidth is
gonna occupy on in our render submission
queue when we actually get around to
that there's a lot of implications that
we don't want to deal with and that we
don't have to deal with if we just kind
of make an extra class that goes on top
of this class basically and then that
will be our controller class because
obviously you know we don't need to
submit we do need to submit an
orthographic camera to the renderer but
the controller should go nowhere near
the renderer because it's just a it's
just a user interaction a little module
that basically could manipulate this
data so hopefully that makes sense
that's kind of what we're building and
so because of that what I could do is
just make another class right here call
it like orthographic camera controller
ortho camera controller but I like to be
pretty specific with my class names we
could do this but I don't want to do
this in this file the reason being that
we need a bunch of stuff for this we
need events we need input we need
basically a whole bunch of stuff that
will basically have to be included but I
don't want to do that stuff here because
again we're trying to keep this kind of
lightweight and I don't want to feel
this this file with input so what we'll
do instead I'll just copy this what
we'll do instead is make a new file I'm
alongside of this file so and we'll just
call it so in the renderer
we'll make a file and we might move this
out in the future because again it's not
really part of the round right in fact I
don't really want to put it there now
we're just gonna dump it in hazel in the
mentions episode we'll go through some
of these things and we'll move them to
core or we'll move them to any anything
else that where they might be long
because yes this is getting cluttered
and hazel dev is not it doesn't look
like this at all
so um something to take note of but
anyway I'll put it in here for now I
don't wanna I don't really want it to be
part of the renderer because it's really
not part of the renderer and then what
we'll do here is make name space hazel
will make that class called orthographic
camera controller and then what that
will be is basically as I said a wrapper
around the orthographic camera so we'll
have that autographic camera and we'll
have a whole bunch of other things here
as well so when we create an
orthographic camera controller the way
this is gonna work is basically going to
be a viewport into our actual view that
we have here so really the only thing we
need for that is to turn is to determine
what kind of projection like I'll say
units we want to deal with so whether we
wanted to be per pixel or something a
little bit more abstract I'm gonna go
with something a bit more abstract I
don't want this to be 3rd pixel per
pixel meaning we would literally set
left and right to zero and like 1280
respectively so that when we use one
unit in this camera it's one pixel I'm
not gonna do anything like that because
we don't really need to and it's gonna
make other things harder what I'm gonna
end up doing is basically just setting
this to by default probably have a zoom
level of one and if we have a zoom level
of one that's basically going to be what
our y-axis is going to be like so
vertically by default when this camera
starts up I want there to be two units
of space no matter the what the screen
resolution is really and then
horizontally will basically have to
multiply our aspect ratio and by those
two units so that we get the correct
aspect ratio horizontally and then by
zooming in and out we'll simply adjust
this accordingly so that basically if we
zoom in we obviously widen the area
sorry if we zoom out we widen the area
so the more as interview and if we zoom
we're effectively just increasing or
decreasing the space that we have in
this actual projection matrix and the
orthographic projection matrix so that
we basically cover less area and thus
everything will be bigger so you will
kind of see this in action and it will
make more sense I think so what we'll do
is we'll actually take in a width and
height now this is just gonna be used to
calculate an aspect ratio we could even
just take in an aspect ratio as a single
flirt with an height yeah in fact I
think we will do that just because this
might be a little bit confusing because
ultimately it's not gonna matter if we
put in 16:9 literally 16 and 9 for width
and height or 1280 720 it's ultimately
going to be the same that might confuse
people wait it's gonna take in an esper
an aspect ratio
okay so we'll store that aspect ratio
and then the other thing I want to store
is an actual zoom level so our zoom
level will set to one to begin with note
that I'm creating the stuff before the
orthographic camera that's important
because we're gonna use this stuff to
initialize the orthographic camera and
the inner fly say the order of
initialization is the order that in
which these variables are actually these
moment variables are declared in so make
sure that you don't try and do anything
like this because if you try and do that
even if you do initialize a person in
the constructor this will be initialized
before these which means that this will
be uninitialized memory because they've
just simply because they haven't been
initialized yet so make sure that you
initialize these two first okay cool so
we'll have that other things we need is
an on update function with a time step
of course this is the this is what I
mean like you know we need to include
time step now not something that
orthographic camera needs at all because
it's just a bunch of data it's just a
bunch of math why not put it needed time
step so we'll just do renderer slash
orthographic camera and then we'll
include our time step will also include
events so we'll do events
slash
we are in yeah I'll just do it hazel / I
really don't like doing because we won't
move this folder in the future so I
really don't like doing relative parts
because everything since we are here we
could just do render a slash event / but
it's better to do hazel slash everything
that we kind of need because that way if
we if and when we move this file
everything will still work and we won't
have to refactor everything okay so
hazel events events dot H will need two
specific types of events in cycle but we
don't need this here at all application
event and mouse events so mouse for like
scrolling and application for the window
resize that I talked about okay
so avoid on update void on events event
E and then private functions will have
is this stuff that I mentioned for
scrolling so this will be bull on Mouse
scrolled let's take a scroll event E and
then on window resized this will be a
window resize event okay cool so we've
got these events now that's great I'm
just trying to think I think that's I
mean we'll probably want other stuff as
well but for now that should be enough
to get us started so if we pop over to
the CP file I will include the
precompiled header and then I will also
include orthographic camera of course
diet orthographic camera by name space
hazel and now we can just use a visual
assist to create everything for us okay
cool sir let's take a look at what we
currently had and sorry this is kind of
controller and we can basically copy if
there's a whole bunch of code from here
so if we look at what we had here this
was our on update function as far as the
cameras
and then you'll see we also did a set
position and set rotation so what we'll
do is move that to on update we still
need this stuff to be in the on update
function what we don't need is well the
mouse scrolling and window resizing and
going to be event but this stuff still
needs to be as actual like an update
kind of loop things otherwise it won't
be smooth the scrolling doesn't have to
be smooth because our mouse wheel is not
smooth in increments usually so because
of that it's fine to use a like an event
for it but otherwise you could also
implement the mouse scrolling for
example in here you could implement
window resize in here you don't need to
do them as events but we will because
that's a little bit better okay cool sir
will do input for all this stuff we are
inside Hazel's so we don't need to do
the Havel namespace at all I'll just get
rid of this stuff I'm actually gonna
change the keys that we chose here the
reason being that you know left-right
up-down I'm that might be more of like a
character controller thing at the moment
the way that my hand rests obviously it
would be better to use WASD for the
camera just because we wouldn't have to
deal with moving my hand all the way
over to the right side of the keyboard
to access those arrow keys I think
everyone would probably prefer WASD so
we'll just change all these to WASD and
then for rotation which I will make
optional by the way I'll just make Q and
E rotation and in fact what I'll do is
I'll add a rotation bullying over here
to the constructor so this will be false
by default because I don't think camera
rotation is that useful for 2d but if
you want you you know you'll be able to
turn it on and use it so we'll kind of
leave it up to whoever press this class
to decide so we need to analyze that
yeah ok cool and then we'll set a
rotation here so let's talk about our
constructor we need to basically create
a camera so the camera is going to be
basically the left side of the camera is
going to be the aspect ratio on the
negative aspect ratio multiplied with
the current
level which will be won by default
source of literally just negative aspect
ratio and then the right side will be
the same but positive and then the
bottom will be basically the same so
negative zoom level right the same
without the aspect ratio is what I mean
and then zoom level will be the top side
so basically this is effectively
negative one to one in the vertical axis
and then negative well whatever aspect
ratio is which is probably one point
seven eight to positive one negative one
point seven eight to positive one point
seven eight so those are kind of the
units we're dealing with and then we'll
also set up the rotation so AM rotation
and then rotation okay sorry this stuff
we will only do if rotation is actually
enabled otherwise we don't have to worry
about that at all camera rotation our
variables we will probably need truck as
well as the speed so what I'll do is
will include input first of all so I
think that's in Haysville slash input is
it yep okay so input dot H and then the
key cards as well so say stuff like this
this is exactly why I wanted to make a
separate file because there's way too
much stuff to deal with okay coming back
into here let's think about what we need
so we need two camera rotation we in the
counter position camera rotation is just
going to be a float which will set equal
to zero by default and then camera
position will be a GLM effect three and
camera position and we'll set that equal
to 0 as 0 is 0 by default iam making
sure to actually initialize at this time
okay roof speed and rotation speed I
will also kind of move over here so we
will have you know mouths of babes
essentially slow flirts and will say
camera translate
speed equals 1 maybe we'll figure this
out in a minute and then camera rotation
speed equals 1 as well
we'll see what they like so I'll just
react to this to be a camera translation
speed you may want this translation
speed to actually be a function based on
the current zoom level so you might want
to translate faster if you're zoomed
further away and then slower if you
zoomed in but that might be something
that we do in the future ok cool on
event so we're basically to steal some
existing events that we've got I'm sure
we've got them somewhere I mean we don't
necessarily need to there isn't I say
that is just easier to copy and paste
this stuff but we have this hazel bind
event function macro that we can use
which is really suited like easy to use
so we'll use the event dispatcher will
basically give it the event and then
will dispatch based on what we deal with
so we want to obviously handle the mouse
scroll event so mouse scroll event and
then we just bind an event function to
that and then I think because I have not
used this in a while we literally just
give it the function so it's just gonna
be author graphic camera controller on
mouse world so this function here and
that should be pretty much it I think
now we should have mouse scrolled event
already included here so that should be
fine hopefully that compiles and then
we'll do let's like just putting miss
something with the resize event which is
our type and then orthographic and
camera controller on window resize like
that that should be pretty good I think
that's it
it doesn't look like it wants to compile
that maybe just be because now this is
inside event let's see if this got
changed actually to be out of it to be
not a standard function that was a
little quest that we accepted yeah let's
just hit f7 so again see this is related
much to be intellisense in the meantime
we'll just return false here as well so
that we don't get that
so dispatches on remember
I am okay so I just made a stupid
mistake of course this has to be the
statue dispatch okay cool
that looks better so that's basically
how we dispatch our events now we need
to figure out what to do
so mouse crawled event gives us a birth
of horizontal and a vertical scroll so
we'll use Y offset what we'll do is
apply basically there's change the zoom
level by that offset so we'll just say
zoom level minus equals get Y offset and
we'll see what that gives us and then we
have to recreate the camera so instead
of recreating the whole camera I'm gonna
have a function called avoid set
projection this will basically do what
the constructor did so we'll grab this
stuff its code put it in here copy this
I'll probably put it we'll make it the
first thing just because it's it's
pretty important and also it basically
does what the constructor does so we'll
grab this card put it here there's a
nice little live carding session because
I had spent a while I think since I've
typed it this much card and live as well
sir let's see
so over here we basically have to
recreate Oh what am i doing this is
completely wrong sorry this is
orthographic oh did you see that I went
into didn't I hit alt or yeah that's
weird anyway I somehow gone to the wrong
sitting people never mind I was gonna
say there's a lot of code in that class
and here we are trying to keep it simple
so orthographic camera set projections
so we're gonna copy this and paste it
here so this is now going to be just
setting up that projection matrix and
now obviously we need to reset that view
projection matrix and that's it you
could change the constructor to do this
but doing so not as ideal I guess
because then we'd be initializing
projection matrix - it's kind of default
value first and then overriding it which
is not something I want to do really so
we'll keep this separated like this but
I think that's it we should need to
touch the view matrix at all because
there should be already set to whatever
needs to be set - okay cool so now that
we've got that we can actually reset
so we'll probably have to actually set a
minimum for this room level but we'll
worry about that in a minute we'll say
camera
what is a camera dot set a projection
and then we're basically going to set it
to the same thing that it was set to in
the constructor so we'll grab this all
the way over here now the zoom level has
changed of course they will recompute
everything so basically the idea is
mouse scroll is changing the zoom level
whereas window resize is changing the
aspect ratio so we're basically
multiplying those two values so in the
window resize aspect ratio is going to
equal Y dot get a width divided by e dot
get high and these I think are integers
so we need to make sure that we actually
cost them to four otherwise we will get
the zero probably or one or something
like that
okay cool so there we go
regretting everything that should be a
cab not actually sure hazel if this
branch of hazel supports window resizing
so that will be fun to see if not we'll
have an episode on that soon
okay that's looking pretty good to me
actually so we need to set the camera
position we're not doing that so a
camera position sorry I'm camera I'm
camera adults set position to em camera
position and then if we do if we cover
tation enabled I guess we'll set
rotations our camera don't set rotation
to em camera rotation all right so
that's it this is our camera controller
you can see that basically all it is is
just a way to set all the different
values we have inside our camera class
now if we go back to sandbox app we can
strip the rest of this card out so we
don't need anything to do with camera at
all in fact we can just remove the
camera if I scroll down over here I will
change orthographic camera to
orthographic camera control oh and this
make I'll just pull it em camera
controller this will be something that I
guess we will need to include inside
hazel so we have all the graphic camera
or
that's part of the renderer whereas I
guess what I'll do is maybe over here
will include just the orthographic
camera
controller okay so now we have this set
up this should be okay let's see where
else we got rid of camera so begin scene
it still needs a camera of course
so we'll do camera control if I can get
camera and I will have that function so
get back to orthographic camera we will
sorry
camera controller which doesn't show up
yeah great okay here we are
now we'll just do a orthographic camera
reference get camera first mm camera and
then I guess I'll also provide a
constant version just in case we need it
okay cool so we have a constant and on
conservation of get camera all right
so that should be it this is still sad
namespace as much as you try and build
this and see what happens if it still
doesn't work um okay so there's no such
file or directory okay I don't have show
old file selected that's probably why so
if I come back here you can see I
accidentally out of it make sure you use
this show all files thing in Visual
Studio because if you don't it will just
make stuff at the root of your project
directory so if I actually put this into
hazel now and everything else by the way
compiled because we used absolute parts
not relative part so in other words we
use relative paths through the actual
hazel directory which was a compiler
include directory so everything like
yeah but of course an exam box nothing
worked so we'll just we compile that
code okay so no appropriate default
constructor for camera control okay yep
so this is gone now and we need to
initialize camera controller instead and
camera controller so this is just the
aspect ratio which again you could just
kind of we know the way we're dealing
with like a 16:9 thing we're making our
window is at 1280 by 720 so what you
could do is literally just work it out
by doing something
like this really simple you could fit in
with / height here you could put in one
point seven seven seven eight or
whatever you want to do here if you know
that a 16-9 but we'll just keep it
simple 1280 by 720 that is what our
width and height years
so we'll keep we'll set that as our
aspect ratio I think that's it
let's camera position and all that stuff
can also go
so we'll kind of clean this class up a
little bit convocation speed so what did
we order just be politically 180 okay I
said it's like one is that should be fun
and moves people's five so will kind of
remember that just in case we need to
set our camera values appropriately if I
just run this program now that we know
that it could piles hopefully we'll get
something actually rendering on the
screen and maybe we'll even be able to
move our camera and do all that fun
stuff okay so we get a blank screen and
I yeah we just don't see anything at all
so let's take a look at why that might
be happening oh well actually I just
realized I'm not calling any of the
functions we made at all so obviously
it's not enough to just make a camera
control you actually have to hook into
the methods that you need so basically
on update we should be doing camera
controller on update with the time step
so this will kind of be our update and
this will kind of be our render um
they're combined into one function
because there really is no render
function on the game thread on the kind
of application thread what we do is
something called a render submission
which does happen on update and then the
render thread will actually evaluate
that render queue in the future so I
think I had a question about this a
while ago yes there's deliberately just
an update because in any implementation
if you had on Renta it would just be
called like immediately after an update
or whatever there's no point dividing it
into two functions and just you know
making the code base more complicated
than it needs to be okay cool so there's
the arm plate and then we also need on
event so over here is to camera
controller dot on an event I'm and I'll
actually just call it because some weird
syntax highlighting occurs because I
think well event is a c-sharp keyword
but apparently it's sometimes get
used in C++ as well not really sure but
visuals Julia likes highlighting it
anyway
okay cool still nothing I mean we should
be seeing it we should be seeing stuff
even if we didn't have this update stuff
so that's not that far-fetched so let's
see what happens here so camera
controller we set to 1280 divided by 720
which is of course that aspect ratio
rotation is false by default we set
camera to negative aspect ratio times
zoom level which I'm sure is 1 ok aspect
ratio gets initialized first does it no
it doesn't aspect ratio doesn't get
initialized at all
so aspect ratio should be set to aspect
ratio like that in fact we probably
don't need aspect ratio we do it here
we're still storing it but that's fine
just make sure that um make sure that
you're actually initializing it let's
hit f5 again another way to debug that
apart from just reading the code what
binges put a breakpoint in and see that
aspect ratio wouldn't have been a proper
value okay so don't you ASD moves
everything mouse wheel as you can see
scroll everything to the point where we
go upside down which is fine and then
Q&A do nothing embark if I recreate this
with rotation set to true by just adding
another parameter over here in our
camera controller initializer then
acuity should in fact rotate our views
let's take a look at that once it
compiles and launches and here we go
ok CUNY do in fact work they're very
slow as predicted because it did used to
be 180 that used to be the speed mount
one so maybe let's set the speed to 180
will be great to have a an actual getter
and setter for that but we can add that
as needed
by the way that is our attention speed
here translation speed like yeah like
five maybe not sure as I said it's
probably nice to have it as a
function and in fact I might make an
episode just talking about this stuff
because you could have you could have
like a curve to that rotation based on
the zoom level starting up to the
rotation but to the actual translation
speed based on the zoom level so you
wouldn't have to deal with that
also the zooms the zoom field a little
bit I'll actually multiply that by five
point five a little bit too quick I
think so I just multiply that by 0.5 we
also want to make sure that our zoom
level is never less than so basically
what does Clampett we'll say that if the
zoom level just like whichever is max so
we'll do
MCM level or 0.25 so basically we
weren't go below 0.25 that should be
about good so that we don't actually
kind of go true Phi and you can see the
conquer you know further than that
otherwise it looks pretty good to me I'm
probably actually make this point to
five because it doesn't does feel a
little bit too fast the zooming
you can have a zoom speed this well if
you wanted to but I think we're probably
okay and yeah you can see one way in we
move kind of way to be false I think and
when we're out it feels like we moved
too slow so to fix that what you could
do technically speaking and I probably
will talk about that in a dedicated
episode just because it's quite fun to
play around with curves and stuff like
that but basically what you could say is
that this you know camera translation
speed that we set could basically be
equivalent to our zoom level car zoom
level so if you do something like this
and zoom level by the way actually the
higher zoom level is the further out you
zoomed in so that makes sense so you can
see when we're zoomed in we move nice
and slow but then when we zoom out you
know we move nice and fast which is good
in fact a linear curve like this looks
pretty good so we might keep it as that
for now that looks pretty good to me
but we'll talk more about functions and
stuff like that in the next episode
probably so there we go over what
rotation we've got movement
which is pretty cool if we go back we'll
just disable rotation but I think we
need that we haven't tested resizing we
haven't tested resizing so I'll just do
that now quickly if we boot this up okay
cool so if I resize the window then our
camera will hopefully resize but you can
see that I don't think we support
resizing at all properly so because this
viewport you can see is get to cut off
up here so we definitely need to talk
about resizing in the future maybe next
episode or the episode after but other
than that there we go there's our camera
controller it's super simple it's a
class officially just designed to be a
camera controller I think everything
else is pretty good
you could clamp the out zoom level as
well just to anything use s to be clamp
or s city min as well as max to actually
make sure that you don't seem too far
out but I think that's fine I think the
big problem is Dominion too far because
then you basically wind up with you know
flipping your view upside down but
anyway that's it hope you guys enjoyed
this episode please hit the like button
if you did as mentioned earlier you can
also help support this series by drawing
up a drunk on for size that sure no huge
thank you to everyone who does help
support this yeah I mean that's a camera
controller it's really cool to kind of
take this out into its own class and
tweak it as much as long as we need to
get this to be like the perfect camera
controller next time as I mentioned we
might take a look at and I I did want to
actually make an episode talking about
like mathematical curves that we can
apply to certain properties so instead
of having like a boring camera
translation speed which is what we had
now you can see that we basically set it
to be the zoom level so actually
realizing how that works I think is very
important not to mention that instead of
having it linear like it currently is it
might be nice to have like an
exponential curve or something like that
so it might be something that I talk
about next episode we'll see other than
that we also need to fix some window
resizing and then we need to have a
maintenance episode so I'm a mice
how much stuff we end up having for the
maintance episode I might make window
resizing part of that but I think window
resizing is probably a decent topic in
itself to have an insert video so that's
the stuff is coming in the future yeah
thank you guys for watching and I'll see
you in the next episode good bye
[Music]